Right away.
Hi everyone, I'm Swix.
Hope you're having a good build so far.
OK, I'm going to start with maybe something slightly controversial,
which is somewhat making fun of a launch of Microsoft.
This is the GitHub Copilot app which is launched a
couple weeks ago.
And it's basically they're a big rebrand of what Copilot
could be, you know, beyond VS Code.
And you notice like it looks interestingly similar to some
other apps that have been launched recently.
And the way I frame this is that everything is
conductor.
The conductor was kind of first to this form factor
of being an agents command centre.
They all, they all have this marketing line and then
eventually sort of cursor rebranded, windsurf rebranded, codecs rebranded and,
and GitHub rebranded.
And I think this is just less a less an
indictment of the lack of imagination or whatever, or just,
it's just more or less the form factor that everyone
has agreed that we're going to converge on.
This is very similar to everything becoming a crab.
We have, we sort of independently reinvented the crabs at
least seven times on Earth.
And so I think that is the sort of main
focus that I, I was sort of pitching this talk,
I guess when when I was invited to come speak.
And very ironically, the company that I'm advising Cognition recently
yesterday also shipped the agent command centre.
Guess what?
It's the same other thing as well.
It's got some other interesting features with the local to
cloud hand off, but fundamentally the level of distraction is
really shifting from managing individual agents.
You know, we started with like auto complete and starting
starting to manage like individual terminals, starting to team mux
the terminals and have like 12 different terminals going on
and then something more civilized and organized like this.
My own coding definitely looks very chaotic in a similar
way, which with all over all these agent managers as
well, but also multiplexing across cursor across.
Oh my God, I just published my GitHub tokens.
I got to rotate that and other and all the
cloud code instances over there as well.
So that's great.
I think like one of the things that is very
interesting is like it's discovering why we're here, right?
So I spent a lot of my career basically organizing
the AI engineer community and I've, I've been sort of
watching this over the over the last few years, especially
over the last year.
This is an explosion in the community.
I, you know, I've met people across Paris and London
and Miami and Singapore and all these and there's, there's
basically like 6 core themes that I really wanted to
impart on people.
And I think this is the, all the contributors to
what exactly is going on and where we're going.
We're about to go with all this, right?
I think there's a little bit of like anxiety.
One of my speakers in one of my conferences called
it format fear of missing agent time.
Literally like people are doing like polyphasic sleep.
Like I wake up in at like 2:00 AM in
the morning and go like, OK, well, I can just
go hit enter on my agent again.
And before I go back to bed.
And I think like really what is becoming true is
that people used to be sort of in this sort
of big model religion and it is no longer that,
right?
It is it is sort of this model plus harness
combination, which I think is very wonderful for developers like
yourselves and, and really is this idea that you can
actually have a strong influence by shaping the harness in
in whatever way.
It used to be prompts, but now we have so
many other additions to with from MCPS to skills to
workflows to what have you and I.
I do think that that requires a level different kind
of UI to interact with the model apart from just
chat, which I think that's is what we're seeing as
well.
We're seeing also the model labs really transition themselves from
just being like, we're going to output the pure model
towards harnesses that are usually increasingly more and more swarm
oriented.
You can see Kimmy K2 put out like hundreds of
parallel swarms.
And Tropic recently also released a embarrassingly parallel feature to
port their million line code base of Zig into Rust.
And I think that's that's a that's a sign of
things to come.
I also think that there is also just going to
be a lot of humans employed in this area.
So like, you know, that I think there's some job
security there.
And it's funny enough, like it's not even like the
code base of the agents that is valuable because you
can leak the entire source code of cloud code and
nothing changes.
OK, And what do I mean by nothing changes?
And Tropic becomes a trillion dollar company even after all
the source code is pwned.
But also, like I asked the makers of all the
other competing harnesses, did you learn anything from from the
cloud code source leak literally on my podcast the other
day And they were like, no, like we, they were,
we just, it just validated.
They have no secret sauce.
Like we are also doing the same thing.
We've also discovered the same exact thing.
So the Moat is not in the model anymore.
The Moat is not in the sort of the, the
the agent harness.
What actually is it?
And I think, you know, obviously that the conclusion is
that you want to orchestrate multiple agents and really do
the mind meld of human to, to agent other trends
that are, that are really interesting.
I, I do think that the reason that this is
so much enabled now is because you can kind of
be hands off with a lot more model work.
And it only recently happened there.
Is anyone familiar with the, the site?
WTF happened in 1971?
It's kind of like a old economic site.
There's, there's like 1 econ guy.
Anyway, if you're interested in economics and history, there's a
site that that is very famous for documenting like the,
the sharp transitions in econ over the last 50 years.
I think there's another transitioning happening right now.
And that's just, it happened around about late 2025 that
we're living through the the implications of it.
And, and that is mostly because models have transitioned from
being, you know, like requiring a lot of human in
the loop here, it's shown by meter to be capable
of one to two hour tasks suddenly jumping to 10
to 12 hour and 20 / 24 hour tasks.
When that happens, when you have like that 10X in
autonomous capability, you start to have different kinds of UX.
And I think that's very interesting as well.
We see, we see that into the play out here
right here at GitHub with things like cloud code commits.
This is one of my podcast guests showing that's that
some indication of the amount of of get a code
on GitHub written by Cloud Code and which we actually
know because they are very clear attribution.
This is rising to 4 to 5% as of February.
It's probably 10% right now is on the trend to
be 50% by end of this year.
I'm not kidding guys.
That is cloud code.
But also obviously think about codecs and copilot and all
the other coding agents as well.
The I, I did, I did release a podcast with
the GitHub CEO yesterday.
Let me let me see where the the number that
he was presenting was something like 14%.
Sorry, 14 X I'm trying to trying to figure out
where, where the where the quote is year on year.
The the amount of commit growth from the number from
from last year is 14,000 times.
I think that's, that's really interesting.
And, and I think that's like that's, that's like a,
a sign of things to come.
But also I, I, I wanted to also tell you
that like there's agents that are doing this for coding,
but also they're agents that are doing this for unverifiable
domains, like just general browsing and computer use, but also
for design.
And I do think like that is starting to break
out.
Like we're, we sort of have this sort of accepted
wisdom that, oh, it's just going to be for verifiable
domains.
But I think the, the beauty of how people are
training these models is that it is really generalizing because
that's been the entire focus this, this, this whole time.
OK, So what does that mean specifically?
I just wanted to sort of dive right in into
the the point of the matter.
One of the most prescient talks I ever created at
my conferences is the this this talk on how the
IDE was dying.
So Steve Yagi is a creator of Gastown.
He's a legendary guy.
He's the right guy.
Who wrote the Yagi's platform rant?
Does anyone is anyone familiar with the platform rant from
Steve Yagi?
Yeah, it's really funny thinking about his platform rant and
then interviewing Satya yesterday talking about how he wants to
turn Microsoft into an AI platform.
I I leave you to draw those conclusions themselves.
There's there's a long lore of platform history that I
think starts with him and is being written again today
for the AI AI era.
But anyway, end of 2026, they did this talk.
They said the idea was going to die in 2026
and they were pretty much true.
Like immediately the sort of the everything is conducted carsonization
trend basically happened like right after they they did it.
I think it bodes well on you to then think
through the rest of the software development life cycle.
If the idea is that if you're doing all these
multi agent orchestration, like what next?
Right?
Well, the next thing is probably PRS, this concept that
you have to sort of wait for someone else to
approve manually because you can't be trusted to review your
PRS.
I think there's a, there's two separate, there's two versions
of this.
One is the open source version and one is the
sort of internal teams version.
Open source version is the one that is most at
threat because that's the vector by which a lot of
people are sending in malicious PRS or PRS that are
not quite aligned to what the, the the maintainers want.
So instead, instead of pull requests, you can just send
prompt requests and the the maintainers can just adapt it
from there because they just need your intent.
They don't actually need your code anymore.
I think that's really interesting.
Beyond PRS, what is what is after that, right?
Like when you have this many agents code coding 14
times more than you had last year, what do you
actually want to, to, to do next?
Well, you know, like a lot of people are exploring
these sort of goal loops, right?
Like the Ralph Wiggum loop was very viral last year
and now it's basically adopted by every major coding agent.
What that is going to lead to is basically this
closed loop of coding agents being able to verify their
own work.
We've been working on this at Cognition, but also a
lot of other people are starting to increasingly talk about
the depth of the code review.
This is what people are calling the dark factory as
opposed to the the general light software factory.
So if you're familiar with the, the idea of the
token factory or software factory, software factory is, is kind
of what people are converging on for producing large quantities
of software in, in some sort of pipeline.
The life factory is where there's a lot of humans
reviewing it.
The life factory is where there are no more humans
reviewing it.
And that's very, very scary.
I totally understand it.
And yet it is coming because that is what the
multi agent orchestration feature demands, right?
That that is the bottleneck anymore.
So I, I will, I will pause here in case
anyone wants to, wants to sort of talk about the
SDLC.
I do have more resources that and I and I,
you know, basically I'm repurposing these slides just to bring
this up for conversation.
But I think you're all here to get the you're
all here because you're interested in how people are managing
this sort of multi aging orchestration.
Does anyone have like anything that they want to sort
of dive into a little bit more on anything I
talked about?
I was told this was interactive.
So I'm, I'm being more, yes, yeah.
More about what are the ideas that we actually needed
to talk about and you get into how do you
then have user adoption or whatever is on the other
side of the pipeline to be managed?
How are you going to ensure that in the dark
factory scenario?
In a dark factory scenario, what's the hardening at the
end that harness look like?
Because it's about ideas and validation and then user change
management.
Ideas, Validation, user change manager.
OK, there's there's the internal loop and the external loop.
I think you're talking more about the external loop of
getting user, user acceptance.
Yeah, yeah, like we have to.
Have a hard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you want, you know, you want to have a
strong spec as as to what you want to converge
to that does it really starts to be like sort
of one level above just the raw delivery of code
because the the prompt becomes how you validate.
Yeah, there's a Swiss cheese model.
This is the one of our top posts of the
entire year.
So by way of introduction, if anyone doesn't know, I
ran both latent space and AI engineer.
We have, we have a good contributor program and this
is one of the top articles of the year so
far.
The the main idea is that, yes, you, you want
to have that sort of spec specification, but also that
strong test suite to, to manage against regressions.
I do think it's not enough.
I do think that you want to to have that
sort of outer loop of sort of online eval of
like whatever you're, you're shipping in feature flagging so that
you have progressive rollouts.
Those are all just generally good software engineering practices anyway,
whether or not you have a dark factory.
I do think they just become way more important because
you are suddenly shipping like an Uber, like a Facebook
at your 10% scale, right?
Like you're sort of bringing forward all these practices of
very large engineering organizations because you have a very large
engineering organization because you're working with so many agents.
Yeah, something that's.
More scalable?
Higher.
Order that we can use to validate yeah, one of
our top conversations of the year has been with Ryan
Le Papolo who is working on sort of the Dart
factory.
Open the eye.
Ryan Le Papolo who so he wrote this article on
harness engineering where it's, it's basically shipping a billion tokens
a day, which is something like $10,000 a day.
And, and just like, and no code, no human review
as well.
And they recently open sourced opening a Symphony, which I
think, I don't know if anyone has looked into, but
there's a very strong structure to how they're adopting it.
I definitely don't think it is the only way to
approach this.
There's other people innovating in this dark factory space like
strong DM and others.
I do think like you definitely want a strong like
basically we have superhuman coders, but we don't have superhuman
reviewers yet.
And mostly because not really the fault of the agents.
Like we don't communicate enough, right?
We don't have that ability or high bandwidth.
We don't have the neural link to really plug into
the machine and tell them what they want.
So obviously the machines are guessing and they're guessed it
wrong.
It's not really their fault, not really our fault either.
I do think that that just means fast cycles.
So for example, he, even though they have a million
lines of code and they're shipping a large app, they
insist on the compile time of less than a minute,
which I've never had in my professional career as an
engineer.
And, but because of, because of agents, you can like,
you can actually take your sort of garbage collection pause
every day if you want.
And just like make sure you cut all the build
times and optimize everything because why not?
But because you have the, the fast cycles, then you
have the fast feedback and you have the fast feedback,
you have the strong alignments between you and the you
and the agents, which I think is very important.
So I definitely would consider this fringe today.
OK, But things that were fringe last year have become
normal this year.
And I, I'm trying to update my own learning rate
in terms of how this all is going.
Because by the way, this is happening for coding.
But a broad lesson that I try to tell people
is also that that is actually last year's story.
This year's story is that what happened to coding last
year is happening for everything else in knowledge work.
And that's actually the real, the real story, right?
Like we're using all this sort of multi agent orchestration
conductor thing as a way to basically preview what the
future is about to be like.
We as we as developers are very privileged because we
get to live this first before the rest of the
world.
By the way, fun fact, the Opening eye team yesterday
announced that they are merging codecs into ChatGPT.
And so I think, I think this is one of
those things where what you see in the coding world
is definitely going to bleed into the normal world, which
is which is really fascinating.
So I don't know, you can tell your your friends
on what's coming.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Let me take one more question.
I think I had another hand raised somewhere here.
Just on the the software development life cycle, the code
review side, anything in that domain.
So you mentioned 0% human review.
Is that transitioning from 0% human review to just validation
of the spec?
Because you still mentioned there's some sort of iteration with
the human in the loop, or I guess outside of
the loop because you get an artifact to then check.
That does include the validation of the spec.
Some of the best utilizations of goal, like what is
goal?
Goal is actually like you don't tell you don't tell
the agent how to do it.
You tell the agent how you're about to evaluate it
and when it should stop.
And so that is a very primitive form of what
you are actually doing as a human.
You're just taking the time to write it down so
that that is what the the sort of Ralph loop
or the goal loop is.
I do think that there's a few more steps beyond
this.
So I do think like if you, if you look
into the harness engineering that opening a Symphony is doing,
that is the shape of the of the future where
you have basically a very highly detailed spec.
Have you seen this?
Have you guys seen this?
I'm going to pull it up Symphony.
Where's the link?
Here we go.
It is just just the giant list of markdown files,
which is which is really fascinating.
I'll just, I'll just, you know, so they sort of
really, really track down everything in in here and specify
right down to the, the the list you're really programming
with markdown and and English, which is really funny.
But really like what you're focusing on is the narrow
waist of, of a, of any program, which is the
API contracts the, the, the surfaces between modules, the types
and data structures, right?
Because everything else can be figured out from from there.
But this is having a narrow waist helps you contain
the entropy that models can inherently cause and also gives
you some way to verify that you're not veering too
far off, of course, like, so this is like the
best way that we have found.
By the way, this is like 2000 lines of just
prompts.
This is the best way that we've found so far
to write a spec.
This is a gold standard spec.
Most of us don't do this, right?
I don't do this.
I write 200 lines if I'm lucky.
But I do think that that is some some idea
of the shape of things to come if you want
this to be fully automated.
We are, we are eventually like, I think the sort
of ultimate Microsoft vision is that right now you are
using frontier models like the GPTS and the clouds or
whatever.
But ultimately you will have your own personal or your
company model trained on your spec anyway.
And then you don't have to use the expensive models,
right?
So like, I think that that is the Microsoft vision.
We're not there yet.
But I do think like if you have a good
agent platform, that is, it is meant to be your
friend, not open the eyes friend, you know what I
mean?
Like someone needs to be on your side.
And I do think that the the the agent labs
versus the model labs, that is the central debate that
I do talk about.
If you're interested in agent lab here, this is the
agent labs versus model labs debate.
If you're, if you're interested in in reading up on
that.
Cool, thank you for that.
Thank you.
All right, I'm gonna keep going.
I do think like there's a little bit more in
terms like if you if you explored the implications of
the SLC.
I highly, I strongly recommend Steve Yagi's post on Gastown
if you're, if you're interested in like the 8 levels
of the fully LLM psychosis sort of approach.
Let me, let me just find that visual that every
that I always refer to.
Yeah, there we go.
See, I look it up all the time and I
just usually I don't have the Q&A time because usually
this talk is done in 15 minutes, but I get
I get to stretch it out a little bit more.
So roughly roughly this kind of progression, right?
Like that you have you start from like adopting a
single coding agent to then doing multi agent.
This is roughly where most of us in this room
are.
If you're sort of up to speed, if you're not
be be informed that that's where most people are and
then going out to building your own orchestrator, which Steve
Yogi is doing with Gas city now instead of Gas
town.
Check it definitely, definitely check it out.
But also, you know, he's he's well aware that he's
he's ahead of where most people are.
But literally this was November, right where he said this
and it became true round about March, right?
It's not that far ahead, guys.
It's not that far.
OK.
The other thing that I've been covering a lot is
really the need for sandboxes.
This is one of those things where again, it's not
a sexy machine learning topic like GRPO or reinforcement learning.
Just I need more computer because why my agents need
computer because why I need, I need to fork these
things in safe environments.
And just like, you know, spinning up a new git,
git branch doesn't do it for me, right?
Like I need a full fork of my entire environment.
And so this is the Kubernetes problem on crack because
Kubernetes was meant to keep was meant to keep things
alive, but this is meant to be extremely serverless.
And we and our sort of current programming paradigms are
not quite adjusted to do that, right.
The rough idea now with what agents are doing to
our infrastructure, we used to be primarily training and then
we'll do a little bit of inference.
The ratio GPU to CPU is 8 to one.
This is from, by the way, this is from the
CEO of Intel Le Bhutan in the most recent earnings
call.
Things are moving with agents to 1 to one, GPU
to CPU.
This is why there's a coming CPU shortage, not just
the GPU quotes M Altman a few months ago to
a very significant degree where AI inference company and now
not just not just training.
OK, I do think that also I also want to
put you on notice like what you want to do
with multiple parallel massively multiple agents is you want them
to finish as quickly as possible.
So at Cognition, we've been working very closely with Cerebrous
on three, 1.5 and 3C2 coming up for thousands of
tokens per second inference, right?
Like if you're not familiar with your own infant speeds,
you should be, but it's roughly between 50 to 100.
Let's call it tokens per second.
I have seen demos of custom chips, which I which
I'm under NDAI can't say, I can't say which company
it is.
There are public company, sorry.
I can point to Talus, which made a, which made
a really cool demo this year, which you should definitely
check out.
This is their tokens inference of everyone else, including NVIDIA
H200B200, Grok and Cerebras.
These are meant to be the fast ones.
And Talos is over here at 17,000 tokens per second
and this might sound like an exaggeration.
It is not.
I have seen this myself.
We are going to see what with 300,000 token per
second inference.
And this is not for a frontier logic, right?
This is for commodity token logic right now.
And the, all these demos are Llama AP, but we're,
we're going to see this proceed out to the 30B
to the 70 B, eventually to the hundreds of B.
And at that point, there's some saturation point at which
from the vast majority of your work, it will basically
be functionally instant to have to have intelligence.
And you should basically start to think about how you're
going to deploy agents and sub agents to deal with
that or to, to make use of that, right?
Because this is coming on the infrastructure side, we have
made the investments already.
It is mathematically going to happen.
OK, finally, actually I'm going to I'm about to transition
to some sort of more future facing topics.
I'm just basically spelling out what I am extremely highly
convinced it's happening this year.
Like Talas will come up with their full chip, you
know, by end of year and you and you know,
you like, imagine what you can do with like a
communique 2.5 at like, you know, 1000 tokens per second,
right?
Like this is one of those things where like, I
think every 10X changes your usage habits, changes the products
that you can make changes the the sort of impact
that you're going to have on choosing between open models,
which is closed, like anything like that.
These are the transitions that are happening on the fundamental
level that are changing the way that we at the
sort of user level and the product engineering level make
our decisions.
So I'll pause there.
I so we just covered like the compute and inference
side of things any other comments or you want me
to double click on something Yeah and feel free to
shout I can just repeat why you is it the
model is the next model that put us to this
level.
This is all hardware.
OK None of this is research as far as the
the the model training people are concerned this is all
optimization.
So what's going to push us from where we are
now?
Yeah, that's the next part.
Our patron's is going to tell us.
But but yeah, I, I, I think it's a fair
question.
Look, actually the most interesting, the most interesting research comes
from the image community like the, the video Gen.
and the image Gen.
community as far as speed is concerned.
So far on the, on the language and encoding model
community, not really that involved beyond just raw quantization and
research into like numerical precision and, and what have you.
It it is all hardware and making smarter choices on
with billions of dollars.
It is it is the highest states poker game that
I've ever seen.
But yeah, I think I think it's a reasonable question.
Oh, I will I will mention more on the research
domain later.
But I do think that like all these trends are
basically pointing us as users, as sort of end user
programmers and product people to think very differently about how
we utilize them, right.
If you understand the the Moore's Law here, then you
start to know, like, OK, like this is a cool
demo now, but like, actually it's going to be normal
a year from now.
We should probably start planning for it.
Yeah.
So, Mark?
Was on a bit yesterday talking about specializing versus generalizing.
Yeah, as far as compute.
So like training versus inference?
Yeah.
And in part of that talk, it kind of made
me think about this.
If you have the AI model etched on the silicon
in the typical hardware life cycle is supposed to be
5 or 6 years when that model is maybe irrelevant
a year from then, Yeah.
How does how does that shake out?
So, OK, there's a leap here, which I don't think
people have looked into that much.
Not most of these guys are not edging the actual
weights onto the silicon.
The only people doing that are tallest right now.
So, so actually, the the the the specialized inference people,
you know, there's a whole generation of them that kind
of failed to work.
Let's just call it.
And now now there's the second generation is the like
the Cerebrus and what and grok that that are getting
paid.
The third generation are still doing it white hat by
not doing doing the during the short term win here
of burning the weights in.
What's the question on that?
I do think that the tail is very long.
There's still people using GBT 4.1, there's still people using
Llama 3, right?
And because people build a working application, the whole point
of having open weights is that you own the weights
and they don't move your cheese.
And if the, if the application works fine, why change
it?
Why it only gets cheaper?
It only gets faster.
That's fantastic.
So I do think the the terminal value of a
chip is increasing.
We used to model, we used to do some tokenomics
two years ago on on lane space and it was
something like your amortization of a of of a chip
would be 3 to 4 years.
Now it's probably extended in life to 8.
The average of the average price of AH100 has melted
up.
I think I have a time series here.
Give me one second to find it.
By the way, I love using Google for my blog.
It's fantastic only if you have the SEO for it.
This used to be the norm for for chip deprecation.
And so it was kind of like a hot potato
then like you would never start a Neocloud based on
this.
And then chip started doing this.
This is like a four year old chip.
And, and and because we are figuring out how to,
how to make the most out of out of the
inference on, on older chips and the our general purpose
enough that you can sort of just change the software
and and update the new models.
I do think like there's a fundamental limit to amount
of compression that you can have.
And so the, the model size sizes are getting larger.
Any prizes for guessing?
How how do you know how this is not how
big mistrial small is We, we had the the chief
research officer of two scientists of mistrial on on the
podcast.
24 B is small these days.
So we're slowly rising.
You know, this used to be two B1 BI think,
then went up to seven AB and now 24 B
is small.
I think there's some point there'll be like 100 B
That's and that's considered small because at the top end,
we have gone from let's say you know, GPT 4
being like a trillion tokens, a trillion params now to
10 plus for the mythles class.
And I think that that is very normal and and
OK, we're not going to have that many orders of
magnitude left to go.
The rest is the domain of research.
I have 4 minutes to cover that.
Let's go into that a little bit what's coming right,
We have all this guaranteed done you can plan you
can sort of set your clocks by for the next
two years.
OK, what's coming is all the other stuff.
OK, so there's a king.
OK, so this is the, the research agenda as far
as I, I get it, as far as I'm tracking
it for all, all the sort of my researcher friends
that I'm that I'm getting.
And by the way, I think this is all recorded,
which is why I need to rotate my GitHub tokens.
But the king one, OK, they're not all equal weighted,
OK.
Some of them like memory and continual learning, you're probably
going to hear about for the next 5 years and
still not see not a huge significant change because it's
very speculative.
The one that is happening right freaking now is real
time.
And what do I mean by real time?
It is that low latency voice that we will all
promise with the GPT 4 O demo that we never
got.
We I wrote this article on the semi async valley
of death, that cognition where you basically have this sort
of uncanny valley area of latency where you're just sitting
around watching the AI do its thing, but not really
thinking, not really adding value because you can't really contact
switch.
So either you want to stay in flow and be
be really fast or you want to be super async
and there's really no room in between.
But that's how kind of how you want to work
with these multi agent orchestration things, right?
You want to be able to dispatch things in the
background and, and have a good system for, for, for
working with them.
But then have a main thread that is your deep
work.
That is your focus.
That is your highest, most challenging, most valuable task because
everything else goes to commodity inference.
This one, the deep work, the high, high bandwidth inference.
That is something that you definitely want as as well.
And we honestly have not got right.
Like think about all the the the advances and models
that you've seen in the past.
Let's call it two years.
It's just increasing reasoning, right?
Like we pride ourselves on going from like 2 hours
of autonomy to 15 hours of autonomy.
Great, but what about my 20?
What about taking my 2000 milliseconds down to 200 milliseconds
down to 20 milliseconds, right?
The only people doing this right now are thinking machines.
I highly recommend checking out the interaction small models.
They haven't actually released this, so all you get this
is demo videos, but I I do think they put
the world on notice that there is alpha here.
And I do think that that is something that we're
we're seeing as well, right.
So you can cheat on the hardware by investing a
ton in cheap in chips and going all right, I'll
I'll get the chip that gives me 300,000 tokens per
second and that in that way get the get the
latency that I that I seek, but it's not truly
interactive.
It is still going to try to inference 100,000 T.O.K
output reasoning tokens before giving your output, but here truly
interactive, meaning it has micro batches of interaction modeled in
the training data itself.
And I do think that that is something that we
definitely want to see more of like we want to
see that live interaction and mind meld between the human
and machine.
It will seem smarter just by just because it will
better align with what we wanted anyway.
OK, broader research.
The other thing that I'm I'm we just had an
XEI podcast as well.
The the the degree to which agents are eating everything
is enormous.
Like like right now people think video generation is just
like you prompt.
You put a prompt into a video Gen.
model and it gives it spits all the video in
one pass through to that video model.
It is about to be video agents where agents are
orchestrating that video model.
That sounds cheap.
That sounds like, oh, I could do that.
But no, like you don't think you have fully appreciated
what it means to fully enter and train the orchestrator
for specific domains like video agents and similarly for all
all other modalities.
I think world models is the other dark horse that
I would that I want to point you out too.
In the sense of like the models are currently trying
to predict what you are most what what sort of
like the median RLHF person is or the oral environment
is likely to reward.
But them maintaining a world model of what you want,
what you like is effectively that second level of intelligence
of like presence of mind and theory of mind that
I think is is really lacking in in the space.
So there's all these research directions solving each and every
one of these will lead to changes in the way
that we use the models themselves.
I do think that this is one of those things
where that's, you know, hallway conversation as far as we're
concerned.
But I can definitely see like in the research communities
that I track these, these are like the the sort
of top grand prizes right now.
OK, so I think my time is up.
The last thing I'll say is I've been calling this
sort of the agent work paradox.
Agents are doing more work than ever before, but we're
also working all harder than than we've ever worked before.
And that is OK.
That's normal, right?
I just want to normalize that because I'm also stressed
out.
I think.
I think you guys also all feel it and that
that's something that's like common.
It is rewarding because we are the first to feel
it and we are getting the the sort of brunt
of the, the sort of compression of the future, right?
And so This is why I always argue in a
very self-serving way that AI engineering is the last job
because you are the you are the ones to automate
all the other jobs away.
So you guys are in good hands.
Thank you.